all right ann
and uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally oh texas
what part of texas
and uh tell me about uh your childhood
you had both your parents
my dad you know he wasn't never there
you know um just me my brother my sister
and my mom how was your childhood
how was your childhood um it was fine
until
she you know her last marriage
you know after her last marriage then
things changed and it became difficult
you know um we went from
being spoiled and having everything and
then when she got married we had to move
into
a one-bedroom house which it uh left me
my brother and my sister sleeping on the
floor
you know with rats roaches and all kind
of crazy stuff and then
her husband had a son a grown son and
he was um he was molesting us i mean you
know well he started with my sister
my big sister you know and he started
molesting her and everything like that
and then but she would fight him all the
time so
you know once he got through with her
then he started going after me
you know in which one night i was
sleeping like i said we had to sleep on
the floor in the living room because it
was only one bedroom
so i you know i was sleeping on the
floor and
he came to me and you know what i'm
saying and he like
put his hands over my mouth i was laying
on the floor he put his hands on my
mouth like this
and he said be quiet because he used to
always bully us and beat us up and stuff
like that so i was really scared of him
and he um when he put his hands over my
mouth
i was so tiny though you know and
he laid on top of me and i just remember
i couldn't breathe
you know the weight of his body on top
of me i couldn't breathe
you know i couldn't move i couldn't
breathe i couldn't sleep huh how old
were you
i was nine and a half getting ready to
turn no
matter of fact i was 10 10 years old 10
yeah and he was 23. yeah
so you know he's um laying on top of me
and i couldn't breathe and
for some odd reason you know we had an
earthquake
and my mom ran out of the room and she
was like
did you feel that earthquake and you
know and she stopped dead in her tracks
because he was on top of me
and then he jumped off of me like he
jumped back and then he just started
digging in the carpet like this real
hard in the carpet real fast and real
hard like this
like you know a dog was scratching he
was doing like this
and i don't think i can remember i was
so i was so exhausted from him being on
top of me and then i was sleepy too
because it was early in the morning
you know and um
after he did that so my mom she she sat
on the edge of the couch and she looked
and then she
got up and she went back in her bedroom
closed the door and then she came back
out the bedroom
by then he had got up and
went sat on the couch and one thing i
remember basically was them
pouring out a lot of change on top of
the table and
he was really really nervous and when my
mom came back into the room
she kept calling my name and trying to
make me sit up but i was so tired
i couldn't you know i was exhausted so i
you know i was
i was just wondering what the hell just
happened you know
and um i remember
his semen his sperm was on my leg
i didn't know what it was i just know it
had a smell
that just made me get really really
nauseated you know
and my mom she went after she came back
out the bedroom the second time
she looked at him and she was asking me
questions and stuff
so by there she got up went in the
kitchen and got the biggest butcher
knife she can find
and she came towards him
in which he ran into the bedroom like i
said it was one bedroom
so there was only one bathroom in the
bedroom so he ran in there
and right when he was closing the door
she came down to knife like this
and i remember that because the knife
was stuck in the door like a couple of
days because
they couldn't get it out the door i mean
that's literally how
it was one of those thick doors was
literally how hard she hit the door
and my stepfather he grabbed my mom they
started fighting and then that's when he
ran out the room
and he left
and um
my mom came back in the room and she
looked at me she said you know
i'm not going to let you mess up my
marriage because they just got married
she said i'm not going to let you mess
up my marriage she said um
she looked at me she said you probably
wanted it anyway
you don't say i didn't understand that
so now
i didn't really get it was early in the
morning so i they made me go to school
the next morning i mean with no
explanation no one talked to me or
nothing they just asked me stupid
questions and i went to school that day
and i was just numb
the whole day and i think that's when i
started being withdrawn
and stuff like that and
when i got home from school all my
things was packed
and excuse me my mom took me
to my grandmother's house in the valley
and just dropped me off
and she made the statement again i'm not
gonna let you [ __ ] up my marriage
you know and um
she dropped me out there and it seems
like my grandmother she was really angry
with me because that was her only
daughter so you know she's on the side
with my mom
you know she seemed like she was very
very angry with me
about the situation you know what i'm
saying and no one talked to me console
me
nothing it was like it just seemed like
they just made it to be my fault
like i did something wrong so now i'm
staying with my grandmother
and it was hell because it's like
she hated me it's like um
she wouldn't buy me clothes or anything
she used to go and you know have people
throw away clothes in the dumpster and
stuff
she thought you know she would go in the
dumpster and get clothes and then the
clothes that i had to wear
to school and everything like that okay
so now
about a year later um
her husband my grandfather um
started molesting me you know
he started you know doing oral sex on me
you know
he's my [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
and it's like
at first i thought he was just torturing
me because he used to grab me and pin me
between his legs
and he just you know scrub the [ __ ] out
of my neck with alcohol until it was
just
red and bruised i mean it was just
straight towards he's always grabbing
but i didn't understand it then but
as time went on i understand what he was
doing he was grabbing me and he was
putting my head down in his crouch
because he kept my head right there on
his dick
and he would just scrub my neck scrub it
scrub him scrub it
and you know i said if i didn't do what
he say he would you know
do all kind of bad things to me you know
beat me
pitch me you know one time he took a
knife and stuck me in my back with it
not really i mean it bled a little bit
but not really deep
you know he's you know he used to be the
extension cords
and whatever they can get their hands on
so that's going up there
and then about you know i wasn't really
used to it so i started being really
withdrawn and stuff like that
and i started stealing you know and
all kinds of things and stuff like that
so by now
when my grandmother found out that my
grandfather was molesting me because
he was taking me to the back of the
building and you know how you go into a
car stall and then they have the like
storage place above the car stock
he would actually make me get crawled up
in there and he would get his big ass up
in there
and that's what he would molest me and
he used to choke grabbed me by my throat
hold me down choked me slapped me
spit my face made me open my mouth when
he spit in my mouth
you know what i'm saying to tell me i
better swallow it and if i didn't
swallow it
you know he would beat me and you know
saying it's like one time
he took a belt like a sp like a real
stretchy belt
and and he's like telling me to get on
my knees and i was crying i was telling
i didn't want to do it please
just leave me alone and because i was in
the back i was trying to hide i was
playing with my baby dolls actually i
was playing with my dolls
because by now i'm withdrawing so
everything that was happening to me i
used to um
um how do you put it um acted out with
my dolls
you know the things that was happening
to me i used to recreate it
yes with my dolls and stuff like that
and i would sit there for hours doing
that and crying
and stuff like that but he took this one
time he took this belt
and he wrapped it around my throat and
he just pulled it and squeezed as hard
as he could
and all i remember is blanking out and
when i came to
he was making me drink his piss because
he had one of those
bags you know he had a catheter and
slowly urine he went into a bag
but he took the tube out of his dick and
stuck it in my mouth and was drowning me
with his piss
you know i'm saying it had that belt
around my throat so i was getting choked
and drowned
and pissed at the same time just
straight torture
so by now my grandmother and then he
would also give me money too
hush money which didn't matter to me i
was just scared to death
so my grandmother found out about it
because she went in my wallet check my
wallet
and um she asked me where i got the
money from so i told her
from grandpa why did he give you some
money so i told her
so the next day after that after i told
the truth i'm getting shipped
back to l.a you know and i'm like wow
so when i got back when they should be
back to la that's when i started
um just really like acting out and stuff
like that
you know what i'm saying i was always
shy and stuff like that
but um
these i mean i just give people stitcher
cards back and candy corn i mean
whatever kind of chord they can find the
thickest chords you can find the
thinnest chords you can find they used
to beat me with i mean you know
webs all over my body and back then they
didn't have child protective custody so
did nobody care because when you went to
school the principal was able to whoop
you
you know what i'm saying and and so i
went from getting beat at home
to get beat at school getting tortured
by my sister
and all the rest of that stuff endless
and then um
as i grew up and stuff like that i
started trying to
you know i kind of like started running
away and that's the first time i came
downtown was when i was like 13 years
old i ran away from home
because i you know i knew she was going
to beat me
really really bad because i stayed out
too late and i just didn't want that
beating
i just knew it was going to be really
bad so i came down here
downtown and um i remember staying in
tent city
and all kind of vacant buildings and
stuff like that
and so much stuff would happen but you
know
it's like it's really hard today because
everything
you know my whole childhood took me you
know i didn't have a childhood
you know excuse me
um i went from being a child
you know to having to be grown
and um deal with everything because it
seemed like no matter where i went what
i did
some grown ass man was molested me you
know i mean
and i remember
um when my virginity got took
it was took by a little boy my age
you know um i wasn't expecting it i was
with my friend and
we went down into the basement apartment
and
i didn't know what was going on and a
little boy grabbed me and he just
raped me you know what i'm saying just
took it and everything like that
and that's basically what's been going
on in my life all this time like now
what happened to me um
this week um i was kidnapped
and um forced to be a sex slave
well i can't say the name but um so you
work figaro
yes and a person that i know
came to me and he said um
he uh had some guys that wanted to um
i wanted a girl he said it was only a
couple of guys and when he said be there
with me everything would be fine
well nothing happened and everything
like that and he said it was for a
thousand dollars so i went
because i needed the money and um
um when we got there basically
the only thing i could really remember
is everything was going fine at first we
smoked marijuana and
had some drinks but i only had one drink
and i didn't even finish it all i
remember is waking up
and i was hogtie you know i
i don't remember when i went out or
nothing i just know that um
when i woke up i was face down
with my hands behind my back and and my
feet was
like up like they had my feet tied but
my hands and my feet were tied together
to where they was pulling together like
this
and i could just remember the pain i
mean my body was hurting i couldn't
stretch i couldn't move i couldn't do
anything
and they had me gag they put
a red ball some kind of red ball with a
black strap
in my mouth and had it tied really
really tight
because i remember the back of my head
right here was hurting and they were
just torturing me
you know they took tasers and um
tased me on my vagina and everything
um they had all kind of dildos
and i don't know what else they you know
um
they just they were [ __ ] me with all
kind of [ __ ]
i mean they shaved my head this is a wig
it's human hair but it's a weird you
know what i'm saying because they shaved
all my hair all
you know they just birthday was just
pulling it out
from the room they're just snatching it
out this happened just recently
yes yes they released me friday
i just i just got back a couple of days
ago i'm still kind of like did you have
a place or anything
no i can't
when you say can't why can't well
if i do and the police don't do what
they have to do
with what they supposed to do and they
just take the report
and stuff like that they found out that
i went to police and my life is in
danger
because of the person that i know who
did you know i'm saying it's like
the police is not the only thing they're
going to do is is make um
a report of it and even if they knew the
person's name or whatever
they're not going to directly arrest
that person
you know they're not going to directly
arrest him so therefore
i'm in danger you know what i mean so
what happened was like the whole time i
was there they did so many things to me
and
i mean at least 10 guys
within them three days maybe more than
ten i don't know i kept blanking out
they um kept making me do drugs
they kept me high off a sherm um
and make me take pills
they wouldn't feed me they didn't give
me any water
and they had me tied down
okay you know one of them plastic um
lounge chairs the the chairs you know
the plastic chairs that being
here there was a hole they had a hole in
the middle of the chair
and they had my breasts
tight like each individual breast was
tied to it was like criss-cross and
going around my throat
and my hands were still bound and my
legs were bound to the bottom of the
chin i ran
around the side like this labels here
this lady's here but it was
bound really really tight and um
they um they wouldn't feed me
they wouldn't give me water they
wouldn't do anything and
every now and then this guy he had a
mask on
i couldn't see his face he had a mask on
his face he came and
he laid he scooted up under my leg and
his face was like up under the chair
right so he kept telling me to
uh piss in his mouth
i'm not i'm like kind of out of it i
don't you know and i'm like what the
hell is really going on you know what i
mean
and um he said he'll give me water
if i [ __ ] in his face in his mouth and
i'm telling
i can't i don't know what to do i can't
do it and every time
i took it if because i couldn't do it
then they was taking wet towels
and just beat me with it wet towels
yeah some wet towels and um
then because i wouldn't pee or [ __ ]
he got up and
um he came from behind me and strangled
me
until i passed out and when i came to
he was laying up under the chair and i
don't really know what the [ __ ] it was i
just knew it hurt like hill
he was [ __ ] me with something i don't
i couldn't see what it was
but he was so you've been working in the
streets for how long
um on and off for maybe
i don't know since i was in school i
stopped i mean after the incident just
happened with my
step-brother and my grandfather and they
brought me back to l.a
you know um i started rebelling and i
wouldn't go to school
i couldn't even tell you where my
classes were or home room i used to go
up there
and you know get the kids high you know
just
drink until i throw up and stuff like
that and then i would leave when the
bell rung i would leave
and just wander around all day all day i
would wander around
to where i find myself sometime in drug
houses you know like where you so
um heroin and stuff um
i would hang out in there or wherever i
could you know what i mean
and um then that's when i started
going to like figure war and everything
like that but is there anything like
what you just went through happened
before
have you had anything crazy like this
happen to you before
no this is the first time you've had
something this extreme
yes i mean i've had things happen to me
but never that extreme
never that extreme you know what i'm
saying does it make you rethink your
decision to work the streets all the
time
yeah but i kind of have no choice right
now because
i used to do hair but because of the
pandemic you know what i'm saying i lost
all my customers and everything like
that so i can't do that
and everything like that so like i say
you know they kept me hustling they kept
me in that house for like three days
with all those different men coming i
mean so many different men and they just
did whatever [ __ ] they wanted to do to
me
you know and first i was rebelling and i
was just like fighting it
but after a while i was just so you know
i just submitted i just
did whatever they wanted me to do
because he was saying he said you know
i won't kill you if you just do what i
want you doing they were filming it
i think it was one of those that was
doing one of those
um first i thought it was a snuff film
and i was going to die
but then then i think it was one of
those hardcore
porns i think it is where you know they
tortured a female and
stuff like that and have sex with them
and stuff like that and it was so many
different men's coming in here
i mean at one point
there were four guys trying to stick
their dicks in my mouth at one time
and they were trying to force me two
seconds i'm you know and i'm throwing up
and gagging
and and they're just
digging my mom digs in my ass this is my
[ __ ] it's just everywhere
i mean it was so bad it felt like i had
a dick in my ear
you know i'm saying i just didn't know
which way to turn it just was just
you know i just prayed and then i made
it out of it
how many days this go on three three
yeah and they kept me drunk okay the
last day
the day i thought i was gonna die they
um
and they kept me tight the whole time
only time they were
they i think they let me go to the
bathroom on a real target maybe twice
and when i went into the bat to clean
myself up and so that's the only time i
got water i had to drink it out of the
faucet because they wouldn't give me
water they wouldn't give me food
um they just gave me drugs
and i think after the first 24 hours
i was ready for those drugs because
those drugs kept me numb to where i
actually was out
i mean it felt like i was outside of my
body
watching me get tortured
you know at one point it felt like i was
just floating and flying
and just like trying to get away trying
to get away
and then it seems like hell it must have
been satan or something for everybody to
snatch me back down and then the pain
comes again
pain comes again one guy wanted to stick
a hot knife in my [ __ ]
and at that point i just knew i was
dying i just knew i was
dead and um
white guy was there he said no don't do
that
you know um he wouldn't let him do it
but he got that guy right there
that one with the knife i mean he said
it on that fire and that [ __ ]
was glowing red
and he wants us to get in my [ __ ] he
wants to cut my nipples off he wants to
do so many
i mean i'm like what the [ __ ] what did i
do to deserve this
you know why me and um
i don't know what it was the one guy one
guy out of all those people
stopped him from really really hurting
me like really bad like that he wouldn't
let him do like
um physical arm to where
it would show you know what i'm saying
so apparently and as i was looking
around and stuff like that at one point
because they had this mask on my head
and
it was like a mask it covered my eyes
and then it had a red bow
with elastic thing on it in my mouth i
couldn't say [ __ ] scream do nothing
um they knocked my teeth out
yeah you're missing teeth
oh this it's still swell right now but
uh
you know um
hold on you had your teeth knocked out
this just a few days ago
and you had them put back no they're not
there let me see
oh jesus oh my god
yeah so um
i mean it was awful
it was crazy i mean
i remember some of the stuff but
a lot of stuff i don't remember because
i was in and out i kept passing out
from the pain and um
well i didn't realize i was here for
three days until after i got back
on this side because they took me and
dropped me out on the freeway
i don't know which one it was but they
dropped me off on the side of the
freeway
[ __ ] naked and some guy
pulled over sir you're right let me call
that card but i said please don't just
just please just take me
home please and he gave me a jacket
there's some boxes okay you know he had
closed the case tell you i put on a pair
of his boxes and he gave me a
big coat that like covered me up i have
no shoes on
you know um my toe
um i just covered with fingernail polish
but it's really hurting really bad
because
this toy they ripped the nail out you
just told just
i mean they did so much so much you got
to work the street to be
yeah cause when i got back uh where i
live
they thought i wasn't paying the rent
because i stayed in a motel so
um they basically threw all my stuff
away
so now i have no clothes no shoes no
nothing
and um
i asked them why would you do that and
they said you know we didn't think you
were going to stay because you would
have been gone three days no one heard
from you or anything like that i said
you could have put it destroyed anything
and um i did get seen by the paramedics
but i lied about my name and wouldn't
tell them the whole story i just wanted
to get treated and that's when i first
got back
you know your family your family
yeah but not out here i have no family
here
so that's why i mean you know even after
all this happened i still have to go out
in the street let me get this soda
i still have to get go out in the
streets and uh
do what i have to do because right now
i have nowhere to stay i don't have any
food no clothes no shoes no nothing
i basically have to you know borrow this
just to come here you know what i'm
saying um
it's just real real hard right now it's
crazy as [ __ ]
it's real crazy i'm scared to death
to be out there but i have to be out
there
i have no choice i mean what am i going
to do
if i'm in the streets and i have nowhere
to live
something like that could happen again
what does this make you do
huh how does this make you feel in terms
of how you view men
what men yeah how can you how can you
view men
after this and not be afraid of them
first of all because i'm a child of god
and
he says are we supposed to forgive
it's hard for me to forgive right now
but
i don't like being touched right now i
don't i mean by the grace of god
things have been a little easy just a
little bit easier to where i don't have
to have
well i haven't had to have do too much
to
get any money you know i just think
that's guy well just helping me out a
little bit but
this will be the easiest easiest hour
you ever spent
i'm serious this is crazy i'm like you
know i really don't want to do this i'm
like why me well i got to go through
this
am i crying my eyelashes but
i want to just ball up in the night and
just
disappear right now and disappear right
now but
i can't i mean you know something's
telling me i have to survive i have to
live i have to
get past this you know
and i see my friend today and so she
said well
if you do this and maybe you know
someone can help you with a little
change so you can get some food and
[Music]
get a room i haven't even had a chance
to
deal with all this
i i guess i'm still numb right now i've
been so
i mean constantly drinking i've been
missing hennessy with chiquita and
smoking weed and you know that's why i'm
sweating right now it's like talking
about it just
it just it just
you know it's hard for me to deal with
man right now
but at the same time i can't judge
everybody buying what other people did
we're not
no i can't do that yeah i mean because
everybody you know didn't do it to me
you know just specific people but
every time i have to get in the car
excuse my name and suck a dick or let a
man touch me right now
it just kills me inside it's just so
it's just killing me it's like i get
nauseated i want to just throw up i just
friends
but i don't want to feel that way you
know what i'm saying because
uh i guess oh man because of what
happened
you know because i know everybody's not
bad like that
you know but it's not hating men
is more or less hating what i have to do
and what i have to deal with you know
really is really hard well and thank
thank you for sharing your
horrifying story and uh i'm happy that
the money i give you is going to be the
easiest money you've made yeah in a
while
i'm going to maybe get some clothes food
in the room
for tonight i'm sure okay thank you so
much for
for sharing it thank you be careful out
there i will
jesus
you